turned down for what
i forgot how the beat goes but we got
some gravity falls here yeah
yeah
look out now we're fully geared up am i
gonna be able to react to that i just
got a new problem presented my way
would stay here
i'm gonna have to pull this off to the
side and look like malibu's most
fortunate
yeah yours is just as complicated
see my face here we go there you go all
right
we're watching gravity falls thanks
david gandy for these yeah i love you
buddy elsa guys this journal
journal
that everything's in here real we can
conjure the gourd face
guys leave a like we're going to watch
episode 5 today and also uh check us out
on patreon for all the goodies we got
including full length watch along here
for you super sexy rejects and a big old
thank you to the peeps at prepper for
editing down these highlights
let's get to
[Music]
it all to waddle say oh girl dude
that was my nightmare growing up just
doing my job hambone i'll see you dudes
tomorrow bye serious nice zeus night
zeus
hi claps you ever wonder what zeus does
when he's not here at the mystery shack
no not really not once ever i have
reggie is engaged but he's like the poor
man zeus i do not want to pressure you
but you are a man now it's time for you
to start meeting girls i would like to
see you settled before i ascend to
heaven and live with the angel oh and
with grandpa no he is not there
i've seen heavier guys get so much
action it's about confidence i've seen
heavier guys get so much more action
it's a way more natural way to say that
a tamber that suits the words would you
want to use that nickel to get a nugget
from old goldie
uh
watch this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there's smoke coming out of his ass
no okay seriously mr pines it's time to
throw that thing out its face reminds
everyone of the inevitability of death
but it's so cool but old goldie's a
classic showstopper like me
kill it kill it
[Music]
a woman
killer
and then em bomb her body to say words
that makes romance happen
your face is good i'm a seuss
he had it coming i i think i was
flirting but i'm not sure
did someone say flirting
well i sort of promised my grandma i'd
get a date by the end of the week but
i've never actually been on a date
before you belong on me out of order
sign ah
zeus a little advice you need to get
rich or lie about being rich outside of
that i don't like your chances
and make a good wealthy billionaire
seuss
zeus you help us so much it's time we
help you dude we're gonna get you that
date we're taking you where romance
lives and fashion styles die
yep build a beaver all right zeus are
you ready to explode a charm bomb on
these poor unsuspecting ladies eat cute
[Music]
hey there i'm not scared of your eyes at
all i'm gonna look at that
wow
conversation
you know i've uh actually been in a
pig's body did you know pigs have a hard
time walking backwards
not you though not that i'm calling you
a pig where are you going
confident
edgy on purpose
[Music]
what is this living nightmare why do
kids love it so much
oh no willie badger i love you
take my money take it all oh
mine you're in over your head gramps
animatronics is a young man's game
you couldn't handle the hardcore life of
a pizza robot manager
flinched sounds like pulshier
oh no cousin reggie i gotta hide
this is it seuss lifetime of loneliness
you're the only ones who could love me
fighty hog dr punch head md
huh
no here we go yes
[Music]
oh good this is suggested whether you're
2 000
[Music]
squid
oh
hi there nice i'm a school girl at
school university now you helped me
carry my books today i went to school
university
[Music]
wow i'm learning and games are making it
fun that's
edutainment man this game is amazing i
don't know why anyone abandoned it and
i'm sure he'll never abandon me new
boyfriend
it's almost like you're actually alive
yes
almost
every time you compliment me i get
another highlight in my eyes uh you're
pretty
and pixely and so agreeable
[Music]
[Laughter]
my
i'll be back i swear
zeus you don't have to wish it goodbye
it's just a game it's not like it's
going anywhere
yes it's not like i'm going anywhere
yeah
yes
wow how people ever get it back inside
my purse oh no undo undo
you can't undo who you are
this is a metaphor for pornography
addiction i am not an ordinary game i am
[Music]
[Laughter]
what did you do to them
so what do you want to do now anything
you want zeus
being an adult is the worst skewering
meat remembering to pay bills i just
want to ride tiny trains all day you can
ride his tiny train all day you know
what i'm saying i'm melody by the way oh
i'm soos i tell you if you like robots
for kids you should check out the best
restaurant of all time you mean who are
owl's pizza
jamboree what you've heard of hoo-ha
owls i love that
she's grabbing a ponytail you know it's
a sign of being invested and wanting
someone to notice you oh it's like a
woman animal institute i learned it from
a nature documentary
you talked to a real girl and you got a
date are dirt
this is the best day of my life that
game really worked you don't need it
anymore you can toss it out
oh
yeah just get an ipad of course i am
programmed to find everything you say
interesting
no one loves you more than me the girls
out there will just make fun of you you
you really think so now sit down in that
chair i don't think i like the way
you're acting i won't let another girl
take you away from me
she's begging the glass yes
i'm taking you back to the video game
store after my date with melody
oh no
oh god i hope you have backups nothing
you can say will change my mind wendy
sometimes a man has to steal an
animatronic badger to stay in this crazy
game called life can do this seuss just
remember what your love crew taught me
what are her stories interesting and
who's gonna pay for dinner saucers now
date
i've heard of going to the table there
oh hi seuss melody are you ready for a
date with
me
i totally am
oh
good show man way to warm them up
oh i wish i was more like you
this is a really suggestive episode yeah
that's kinky
you're hilarious
well you know i just sort of say
whatever pops into my uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh could you sit tight i have to go to
the bathroom for a long time not in a
weird way
[Laughter]
she's not real
[Music]
tiny enemies uh-oh take it from someone
who brought an arcade game to life this
will not end well don't worry i'm pretty
sure she's stuck on tv screen
wow
zeus what's going on no time to explain
we got to get out of here
[Music]
yes
five nights at hooha's
sorry zeus but you can't run away from
our relationship
oh
that is dangerous yeah i'll distract her
while dipper and mabel keep you safe
it's the only way seuss these are
children
the only way
how can you handle that pace yes
there you go buddy
stay back you monster
oh no yes
yeah
you really think melody is going to take
you back after this awful date
i can download your brain into the game
with me and we'll be together oh cool i
say game over tiffany
no way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
yes
you did it you old beautiful monster you
did it how's about you and me hit the
town these old husbands are going to
vegas
[Laughter]
spirit of love we did it
yes yes i am so happy have you been
following us all day
sue says life is my soap opera
and i went to vegas
[Music]
[Laughter]
how progressive turned out
i don't care what anyone says
that episode is a metaphor for
pornography addiction
can absolutely see how that is true
they say that like a lot of kids who
grow up consuming that
category
on the internet
it messes with their
you know social skills and inability to
actually only know from like
heterosexual manner i don't know if it's
what it's like for
other
orientations but yeah it messes with
your like uh
all the things you were talking about
were basically what zeus went to the
mall i was like oh that's what i always
heard happens with like kids who grew up
on
extremely graphic stuff and now
committing his life
to her you know what i'm getting at i'm
trying to watch my words here because
i'm skipping mind this is also kitchen
that's engaging along really dismissing
what i'm saying virtual relationship
that if endures will then progress
via the internet much like a lot of
things wanting instant gratification
because on certain websites you can
get that instant gratification
that expectation that predictability as
said here whereas in real life it's not
the same thing
and uh
so it does
create default i'm going to keep it at
that i don't want to get too deep into
it right now on the gravity falls
i i mean you know they're they're
subconsciously planting the lesson into
kids minds
so that when they come across this stuff
on the internet they think to themselves
nah
i'll hold off until i meet my own meet
cute yeah lady
this episode was awesome this is a lot
of fun this is great yes i love this one
really cool i love relationship thing
relationship themed stuff that's uh it's
been my favorite category of things
always has been
and
uh
this is the kind of thing you could
totally see being a movie
yeah yeah oh yeah this could easily be
transcribed into a feature this is like
the exactly you have the exact plot of a
movie where yeah zeus is looking for a
date falls in love with the girl first
half of the movie it's all fun
and then the midpoint it's like oh yeah
i think i finally found what i want
ready to date but then everything starts
to crumble and then the b story being
the animatronic plot
with uh you know wanting to obtain the
chuck e cheese knock-off thingy and then
it all comes together in the end i think
that i think there's like an actual like
plot here and then yeah it could be a
movie and i think that's pretty cool to
see an episode of television that
essentially told a really well done
short version of it
and uh i really cared about this is my
favorite zeus episode yeah absolutely by
a long shot yeah i always enjoy uh when
you know the requisite we've been on
long enough to shift the focus to a side
character kind of episode and yeah to
get soos in a more direct and
i'm not like only there for the
punchline capacity for me i thought was
fun uh but yeah
it's like her but if instead of just
gaining independence the ai went nuts
and then the movie culminated at a chuck
e cheese instead of just you know
out in life
yeah but it was like one of those uh you
know uh compute those computer ais that
can just
that's like a surveillance level can
hack into anything yeah it's like
child's play the reboot yeah yeah it's
like god mode yeah at all times and uh i
thought i thought that was excellent
yeah it was funny it was really funny it
and uh
uh
it it was like i don't wanna say tension
but there was like stakes to it there's
actual apparel there's suspense i think
there's an extra layer of tension or
stakes or peril that can come out of
when you're watching animation that is
like skewing a little bit older into
places you wouldn't necessarily expect
it to go so like the themes can almost
create a certain sense of tension
alongside whatever wacky circumstances
are happening and i think that's kind of
what happens during gravity falls is you
get that sort of sense of danger
sometimes of like oh man we're kind of
getting a little bit mature suggested
yeah
and it's fun to be able to indulge in
that flavor and witness that sensation
well uh the girl too who ended up taking
a liking to zeus what's her name melanie
melody melanie there we go melody i
thought i think i like the way she was
written yeah she wasn't
you know some
cooped out crazy character who can
get on board with zeus's wacky
sensibilities
she seemed like a down earth
there was a type of personality that
i could see
she's the one who could like zeus yeah
it was believable you know sometimes you
pair these characters up when these
dating scenarios and the other
characters usually like super wacky in
some way and they didn't do that
um
yeah she can see
through to the person in him that a lot
of his wackiness is just attempting to
kind of you know protect and i like to
that you get that lesson of like you
know whenever anybody i think is
self-conscious about trying to date or
strike up a relationship or whatever
there are so many pressures that come
out of that from family members from
friends all of whom mean well but want
kind of a different thing
for you but also for themselves and then
you know you get that that nice kind of
realistic
unfolding of events where it's like yeah
when you go out and you're like okay i
gotta try and i gotta keep all these
things in mind it's like of course it
comes off awkward and stiff and then
when you're sort of just you know in a
moment of uh where you're not even
focused on that is usually when you
actually make a connection and start a
conversation some with somebody and i
thought it kept a nice eye on that where
yeah when she when she sees him it does
feel quite natural and it feels like
somebody who you could see plausibly
being you know endeared towards seuss's
wackier qualities but who can also see
yeah just and talk to the person that he
is without immediately levying a
judgment or something like that like
they
in a perfectly proportionate level to
the medium that this is they made it
feel very nice and natural that they
might you know strike up a relationship
and two i thought it was a nice beat
that they were like yeah she's not gonna
she doesn't live here you know this
isn't gonna be like
somebody he can afford to
you know fixate on completely like
you're gonna be my soul mate forever so
like i don't know yeah there was some
nice like nuance
nuances to
just that you know
getting out there and and making
connections with people's story
well i like this story in total because
i like a good escalations i love the
kind of horror stories where
it starts off like this is a gift
yeah it's really a curse i really i
really like those those are those are
generally my favorite kind of horror
movies and
yeah getting off on this note that seems
like this is all positive you know it
was a burning date and then
uh and where it went i like how they
really went all out and they got like
creative visually there's like this one
shot where she's in the
the the the
the character video game character is
embodying one of the animatronics and
then the arcades are doing that like
that mirror reflection it's her in the
mirror like her she's in the screens of
the arcades i think that was a really
awesome shot which which reflects a lot
of that that's a common horror thing to
do
um you know the real identity is present
in the reflection yeah uh but overall i
think the way they also tied the stories
together because sometimes the because
they had two game related or electronic
related stories one being about
animatronics which was kind of okay uh
uh uh
uncle stan's um obsession with wanting
to get it
i i i felt kind of that sitcom writing
with wendy of we don't really know what
to do with her this episode let's just
have her be so
so begrudging towards this whole thing
you know
but
it was still it was fun where i thought
it landed uh with the animatronic and
finding him at the end
so yeah that was all good it was a good
episode guys it was a good episode yeah
that mostly felt like a device to get
them there to justify why they were
there like it was always funny but it
didn't feel like grunkle stan's
involvement actually affected anything
to do with the episode other than it
being very satisfying when goldie comes
back yeah but even then it's not like
they really needed that from him you
know with everything else going on
well sometimes the
the pursuit of money for uncle sam now
that we know more of his true motives
uh
i'm not
sometimes i question what this pursuit
of money is all about
when you've got a way bigger fish to fry
yeah when you've got a much bigger plot
and bigger unveiling of him and this is
more like season earlier season one
grunkle stan yeah of oh money it's all
about money
and i'm a shyster yeah well you know
he's much more than that and no one else
does but he seems like okay so he really
does want to uncover the true mysteries
but also he can get really distracted by
the pursuit of money capitalism
this is one for the one for the memory
books i thought this was a really
charming really funny one yeah yeah all
right guys well
tell us
would you date an ai
i think it could be fun the time's
coming you'll be able to answer that
question for real soon enough i think
it'd be totally fine
yeah why not
he's dealing with someone nagging you
yeah i mean you know you can just go in
and tweak the code man
except that would be messed up that
would be a violence i'd be controlling
it right yeah
it seems like
it wouldn't
the the the the sole motivations for
dating an ai would have to be
circumstantial to the to the
interplay of consciousness and machinery
yeah
not for any other reason
all right guys well thanks for being
here and uh hey let's do
maria hammond
maria
we shot brooklyn nine-nine wearing the
clothes that you gave us
and uh the hat too
and we didn't shout you out
so david ganny has given us these hats
we're gonna shout you out just gotta
loop it all the way around the match
it's a continuum but i was talking to
you on twitter the other day and i just
want to say that i hope
that
things start looking up
soon
and i understand the emotional
rollercoaster quite well
and also with what you're telling me
about the other fellow youtuber that
you've been helping i think that that
speaks volumes amongst the good heart
you have what stood out to me though
was
you were helping out another
youtuber
when i thought we had you just for
ourselves yeah
so
i don't know do i really want to be in a
polyamorous type of
subscriber
[Music]
youtuber
we expect certain people
you being the only one we expect it's a
contract yeah that you don't
support anyone else but us
so in any way
i think you you're trying to tell me
that you were doing something kind but i
know that individual who you're talking
about too i know that person personally
have individuals phone number
that's weirder i
texted that person and said
hey
look if you want maria
you're gonna have to fight me to the
death for her
and this individual said that
he's just gonna
off himself
to make life easier
for
which is for us because he knows how
worthy we are and how much we deserve
you because you're in the conflict of
who do i choose because you have such a
good heart
and now
thanks to you
that person's deleted it's a win-win
which makes me happy i'm really happy
that person's gone and i think they're
in a better place
yeah
with the fiery depths of hell the fiery
the very center of hell you know that
person's going there oh yeah so you're
trying to save that person's soul from
eternal damnation but i'm telling you
maria that person's long gone oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah send this shout out
send this shout out to him
pl play it at the wake
[Laughter]
no no we're just joking he's a he's a
terrible person but you're a good one
you're good you're good but he's awful
mr j
[Music]